[Music]
cheers sweetheart
darling I'm just going to get any
wineglass good idea oh don't worry
sweetheart
your father will not misbehave come on
bringing home a human I'm sorry I just I
don't get the point that was like the
lamest joke ever
and honestly I'm in love isn't that
enough it is I see two points timing oh
you know it's it's uh it's important
with joke son next time sweetheart
okay mom freaking stupid yeah freaking
idiot you freaking adopted wait what
what time does he get oh I'm sorry guys
that must be Curtis I told Unger's comer
it in Holland by the way I didn't tell
more vampires I just said you know we
were black all time I mean sometimes
sleeping coffins and can't go in the
daylight so that's cool right
what what's up man I'm friends with
these guys
no I'm a brother like brother from
another mother got angry right adopted
brother easy you're mrs. Drac yes you're
her mother
that's me Wow you don't look a day over
20 look great he's a keeper and he's
cute I really like what you guys did
with the place all we're in black and
super gothic you guys have really big
sharp teeth runs in the family
Oh got like one sharp truth right there
but nothing on you guys so outwards dig
in okay is that raw who made this [ __ ]
well you don't [ __ ] them now I mean I'm
actually feeling kind of sick where's
your restroom down the hall my writer
you're right you're right okay
dessert yep definitely bucket I feel
better
feel much better
let's get we want to try your meal
before we move on to dessert tetanus you
guys are gonna love it isn't me yeah but
it's good it's really good you're gonna
love it trust me
let's break fan garlic lots of garlic
ah yes garlic bread why look guys we're
Italian is this
that's pretty good
[Music]
you